he's a person that makes everyone around
him better I don't think he's just an
MVP on game day his whole process
leading up to the games is MVP caliber
always the first one in the building
always the last one leaving the building
watching film and then his energy at
practice making sure people running the
routes right putting energy out when
people ask me in week nine why I thought
Dak was going to be an MVP candidate
I've seen the work and the GE he's
putting together we're going to be
looking at one of the richest men in
America I know dak's going to take care
of me for the rest of my life because
I'm supporting him thank you D I'm going
to let you adopt me since you're having
a daughter here in March congratulations
on that too